anlässlich aktueller Beschaffungen des
österreichischen Bundesheeres an meiner
Seite darf ich begrüßen die
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
und den rüstungsdirektor Herrn
Generalmajor Harald wodoseek Frau
Verteidigungsministerin ich würde sie um
ihre Worte
ersuchen guten Morgen grüß Gott sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der Medien sehr
geehrter Herr Generalmajor
wodusek es ist ein freudiger Anlass zu
dem wir heute vor ihnen stehen ein
freudiger Anlass für mich vor allem aber
für das österreichische Bundesheer
getreu unserem Motto Mission vorwärts
können wir heute einen weiteren großen
Meilenstein verkünden ein Meilenstein
für die Zukunft unserer
Luftstreitkräfte sehr viele von ihnen
wissen dass ich Anfang des Jahres gesagt
habe dass wir am Ende des Sommers eine
Entscheidung über die Nachfolge unserer
Herkules 130
Transportflugzeuge Treffen werden und
glaub sie kennen m mittlerweile schon
ich stehe zu meinem Wort diese Woche
endet das Sommer auch Kal kalendarisch
und daher sind wir auch heute hier sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren die C130
Hercules ist bereits seit 2003 im Dienst
des österreichischen Bundesheeres und in
diesen 20 Jahren haben die drei Herkules
Flugzeuge viele Einsätze bewältigt und
sie waren stets und sind ein
verlässliches Transportgerät für unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten mittlerweile
sind diese damals ja gebraucht gekauften
Flugzeuge aber 56 Jahre alten Alter bei
dem man zweifellos an eine Nachfolge
denken muss
und bei dieser bei diesem hohen Alter
steigen auch die notwendigen Wartungen
und werden somit
mit jedem Jahr
unverhältnismäßig
kostspieliger nicht zuletzt auch
aufgrund dessen ist ein rascher Ersatz
mehr als notwendig nicht zuletzt auch im
Sinne der Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler es war so um den
Jahreswechsel
20 2021 als ich den damaligen
Generalstabschef Robert Brieger jetzt
der oberste Militär in der Europäischen
Union beauftragt habe die notwendigen
Schritte für die Beschaffung eines
nachfolgesystems in der 20 Tonnen Klasse
einzuleiten ja Generalmajor Bruno
Hofbauer unser planungschef hat dann mit
seinem Team umgehend auch die Planungen
aufgenommen und ein Anforderungsprofil
verfasst ein Anforderungsprofil mit dem
dann unser rüstungsdirektor Generalmajor
wodusek an andere Staaten herantreten
konnte um verfügbare
Flugzeugtypen und
Kooperationsmöglichkeiten abzufragen und
dann auch zu koordinieren auf dieses
anforderungs Profil wird unser
rüstungschef dann im Anschluss noch
näher eingehen es waren ausführliche
marktsondierungen notwendig und es
wurden alle Optionen geprüft und die
Antworten auch der angefragten Staaten
haben ergeben dass die embrea
c390 als einziges Flugzeug in der 20
Tonnen Klasse alle unsere Anforderungen
auch erfüllt dieses Flugzeug ist
selbstverständlich auch der bevorzugte
Typ des
Generalstabs aufgrund dessen habe ich
Generalmajor wodosek beauftragt alle
weiteren Planungen und Vorhaben in Bezug
auf die Nachfolge der C130 Hercules
jetzt auf die emrea c390 zu
fokussieren Sie wissen dass bereits
jetzt andere europäische Staaten auf die
c390 auf die empra fokussieren z.B
bortugal betreibt einige Flugzeuge und
auch Ungarn hat bereits im Jahr 2020
einige C 390 bestellt das heißt für uns
ergeben sich daraus viele Möglichkeiten
der Kooperation zum einen was die
Ausbildung anbelangt was die Wartung
anbelangt aber selbstverständlich auch
die Beschaffung von Ersatzteilen äh
anbelangt wir haben das ja auch diese
Kooperationen bereits bei unserer
herkulesser immer wieder auch eingesetzt
bzw tun dies noch wir wollen eben auch
bei dieser Beschaffung auf Kooperationen
setzen zum einen einmal um den Kauf
kostengünstiger gestalten zu können und
eben auf der anderen Seite diese
weiteren Synergien wie eben die
genannten insbesondere bei der
Ausbildung auch zu schaffen was streben
wir an wir streben bei diesem Kauf der
emprea c390 eine Kooperation mit den
niederländischen Streitkräften an es
laufen zu dieser Kooperation bereits
sehr intensive Verhandlungen und
Planungen zwischen generalmerer wodusek
und seinem Kollegen aus den Niederlanden
diese Verhandlungen sind intensiv aber
sie sind noch nicht abgeschlossen das
heißt äh alle Details können wir Ihnen
heute noch nicht verkünden weil wir
diesen laufenden Gesprächen natürlich
nicht vorgreifen möchten und dies auch
nicht äh können einige Punkte die noch
offen sind ist z.B der genaue Preis auch
der Maschinen und wie viel Stück dann am
Ende des Tages tatsächlich für uns
beschafft werden zur Anzahl aber nur so
viel wir haben seit Beginn der Planungen
von rund vier Maschinen gesprochen und
in diese Richtung werden auch die
weiteren Planungen gehen das heißt dann
auch dass sich der Preis natürlich nach
der Anzahl der bestellten Maschinen und
dem Verlauf der Verhandlungen richtet
grundsätzlich kann man bei diesen
Militärmaschinen von einem Stückpreis
zwischen 130 und 150 Millionen Euro
ausgehen das ist eine
Richtgröße jedenfalls können sich die
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher
sicher sein dass unsere Expertinnen
Experten insbesond unsere Generalmajor
wodosek und sein Team das beste Gerät
mit größtmöglichen Nutzen für unser her
und damit eben für die Sicherheit der
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher
beschaffen werden sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren mit dieser Beschaffung machen wir
einen weiteren großen Schritt hin zu
einer modernen Armee hin zu besserem
Gerät für unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten und hin zu mehr Sicherheit für
die österreichische bevölker im Inland
und im Ausland vielen Dank sehr geehrter
Generalmajor ich darf Sie um Ihre
Ausführungen ersuchen sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ich darf an die Frau
Bundesministerin anschließen und ein
paar technische Daten zu dem
Beschaffungsvorgang C
c390 kooperativ mit den Niederlanden
ausführen die Frau Bundesministerin hat
das angeführt wir haben eine umfassende
Analyse Markt vorgenommen aufgrund der
Analyse hat sich ganz klar ergeben dass
ein Anbieter am Markt in der Lage sein
wird unseren Forderungen zu entsprechen
vor allem die Forderung einen Pandur Evo
mit auf aufgebaauter waffenstation in
den Einsatzraum verbringen zu können auf
der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite eine S70 BCK einen S70 BCK
Hubschrauber in den Einsatzraum zu
verbringen waren ausschlaggebend dass
wir in der Lage waren der
verbundesministerin was dem
Beschaffungsvorgang betrifft
vorzuschlagen dass wir eigentlich zu
einem frühen Zeitpunkt eine
typenentscheidung treffen konnten
der zweite Umstand dass wir dass ich
relativ breit auf den Markt gegangen bin
hat dazu geführt dass wir erkannt haben
dass das unter den eu- Nationen vor
allem die Niederländer zum gleichen
Zeitpunkt mit den gleichen Forderungen
am Markt sind und zum gleichen Zeitpunkt
ein Flugzeug mit fast der ident mit den
fast den identen Leistungsdaten besch en
wollen das hat dazu geführt dass die
verau Bundesministerin den Auftrag
gegeben hat mit den mit den
niederländischen Streitkräften
Verbindung aufzunehmen und im ihm
darüber darüber zu darüber zu
diskutieren welche Möglichkeiten der
kooperativen Beschaffung hier möglich
sind wie gesagt die technische
Ausschließlichkeit lässt es zu dass wir
zu einem frühen Zeitpunkt eine uns für
diese eine Type die
c390 entscheiden wie geht es weiter bei
unserem Verfahren die verau
Bundesministerin hat das angezogen ich
werde mit me meinem niederländischen
Kollegen und den Expertinnen und
Experten aus unserem Haus und aus dem
Haus der Niederländer
über
Vertragsmöglichkeiten
mit den brasilianischen Anbietern
sprechen und wir werden in diesem Jahr
relativ weit vorankommen und wenn die
kooperative Beschaffung stattfinden wird
so wie wir uns das vorgenommen haben
dann werden wir da können wir davon
ausgehen dass wir in der ersten
Jahreshälfte 2024 zu einem
Vertragsabschluss gelangen
werden der Vorteil an der Kooperation
mit Ländern wie den Niederlanden oder
eu- naationen ist dass wir so wie die
Ver buundesministerin angeführt haben
identes Gerät haben keine ölösung
sondern eine europäische Lösung eine
Lösung in einem Kooperationsverbund wir
sind in der Lage in einem Einsatz de
facto ohne Schnittstellen Problematik
Systeme zu betreiben und auf der anderen
Seite sind wir auch in der Lage im
Rahmen der Kooperation unsere Ausbildung
unsere Logistik
undsreersatzteilversorgung unsere
Wartungen entsprechend durchzuführen im
großen Ganzen kann man sagen Vau
Bundesministerin dass wir in der Lage
sein werden im nächsten Jahr für die
österreichische Bevölkerung ein neues
Flugzeug bereitstellen zu können indem
wir den Vertrag
abschließen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Werte medienvertreterinnen und
Vertreter gibt es
Fragen bitte warten bitte zu warten
Mech von der Zeit im Bild haben auch die
Ungarn vor das Gerät zu beschaffen oder
haben wir schon also wäre Ungarn nicht
sozusagen zumindest geographisch näher
ist die Niederlande und ein europäisches
al ein originär europäisches Produkt von
S oder was wäre nicht verfügbar gewesen
zu meinen mal was Ungarn anbelangt die
haben bereits im November 2020 die PRA
bestellt einige Stück davon und die
Niederlande sind eben von der zeitlichen
Komponente genau jetzt im
Beschaffungsprozess haben auch die
Notwendigkeit diesen rasch umzusetzen
und sind deshalb da auch richtige
Partner aber wie es der generalmer wos
auch schon angesprochen hat mit dieser
Entscheidung haben wir
selbstverständlich die Möglichkeit von
umfassenden Kooperationen das war ja
auch jetzt bei der Herkules so dass wir
hier mit mehreren Staat no durchusoper
Möglichkeiten hatten jetzt geht's aber
insbesondere um diese gemeinsame
Beschaffung wo wir uns eben vom
Zeitpunkt her bei den Niederlanden
anhängen werden das ist das Ziel wo an
dem wir eben intensiv
arbeiten ja von wie vielen Flugzeugen
reden wir jetzt tatsächlich wann kommen
diese Flugzeuge also wissen wir dass sie
den Vertrag unterzeichnen aber aber für
spannender für die Sicherheit ist ja
wann sie wirklich kommen fangen mal mit
diesen zwei Fragen an mhm glaub eine
sehr wichtige Frage weil es in der
Vergangenheit in diesem Ressort ja immer
wieder passiert ist dass keine
nachbeschaffungen
passiert sind und die Geräte dann Ende
der technischen verweilau angelangt sind
das System der Herkules funktioniert
noch bis zum Jahr
2030 aber wie schon
angesprochen jedes Jahr bedeutet einfach
zusätzliche Investitionen es sind
Modifikationen zum fähigkeitserhalt äh
äh unbedingt erforderlich und das kostet
einfach Geld daher ist das Ziel den
Vertrag im ersten Halbjahr
2024 zu unterzeichnen und ab diesem
Zeitpunkt kann man dann rechnen
24 bis 36 Monate das heißt z bis 3 Jahre
bis dann die erste emprea in Österreich
in Österreich gelandet ist von der
stückanzahl wir haben haben immer von
vier Stück gesprochen in diese Richtung
geht auch die Planung aber ich bitte
hier um etwas Verständnis nachdem diese
Gespräche gerade noch laufen
ist die Möglichkeit auch von der Anzahl
in die eine oder andere Richtung das ist
die Richtgröße diese vier wo unsere
Experten eben gesagt haben in diese
Richtung ist soll die Planung auch die
Planung auch
erfolgen
wo sollen denn die vier Maschinen dann
stationiert werden ich gehe davon aus es
wird Hörsching sein fliegerhurst Vogler
was bedeutet das auch für den
fliegerhurst ich nehme an man wird
wahrscheinlich auch in der Infrastruktur
etwas machen müssen weil ja die
derzeitigen glaube ich hangas viel zu
klein sind dafür ja selbstverständlich
die Stationierung wird in Linz Hörsching
sein und die bereits dort bestehende
Infrastruktur muss dann entsprechend
angepasst werden das sind umfassende
Anforderungen an einen sogenannten
luftumschlag Punkt und für den Betrieb
eben des zukünftigen
lufttransportsystems da im prer muss es
dazu auch Anpassungen und
Erweiterungen geben wie gesagt das ist
auch eines der Punkte es ist nicht nur
sind nicht nur die Transportflugzeuge
sondern immer auch die Infrastruktur die
wir dementsprechend dann no anzupassen
haben selbstverständlich parallel dazu
auch die entsprechende
Ausbildung warum hat man sich dann
eigentlich gegen die moderne Herkules
entschieden ich formuliere so es war die
Entscheidung für das Produkt das als
einziges alle unsere Anforderungen
erfüllt hat die ja sehr intensiv
erarbeitet worden sind die Phase hat ja
begonnen bereits 2020 21 ein ganzes Jahr
dann noch einmal und ich glaube der der
wichtigste Punkt und der der Punkt wo
der für uns ganz entscheidend war war
eben die Möglichkeit dass man den Pandur
Evo mit der aufgebauten waffenstation
bzw auch schon angesprochen auch einen
Hubschrauber dementsprechend unterbringt
es sind noch ein paar andere Punkte
drinnen eine ganze Liste an
Anforderungen die eben dazu geführt
haben dass für nach unserem technischen
Pflichtenheft dass das einzige Modell
auch war für das wir uns entschieden
haben also eine Entscheidung für die
emrea
390 GEG ber die Frage sie waren glaube
ich selber in Holland bei den
Amtskollegen wie ist nur das
klimakterische oder das klimatische
Entgegenkommen scheinen die
kooperationswillig oder fähig oder
bereit zu sein weiter mit uns diese
Sachen zu
vertiefen
Frau
Bundesministerin grundsätzlich hat die
Frau Bundesministerin für uns einen
Rahmen geschaffen mit ihrer Amtskollegin
beim Meeting in Toledo einerseits und
andererseits bin ich mit dem
niederländischen rüstungsdirektor se
verbunden weil auch ich im Rahmen der
europäischen verteidigungsagentur in
einer Konferenz der nationalen
rüstungsdirektoren verbunden bin Arien
Admiral arienard ist ein ein
rüstungsdirekt der die Kooperation die
die sousagen das das Beschaffen von
identem Gerät massiv fördert er ist also
hoch daran interessiert an Ländern wie
Österreich oder an Deutschland oder
anderen europäischen Ländern diese
Beschaffungen vorzunehmen es gibt also
Beschaffungen mit Deutschland wo identes
Gerät für beide Nationen beschafft
wird zum zum Klima kann ich nur sagen
höchstkooperativ die Niederlande sind
sehr dran interessiert mit uns zu einer
klaren deutigen Lösung zu kommen und
dann auch in weiterer Folge mit uns das
Flugzeug bereit betreiben zu wollen also
wir haben im Prinzip innerhalb kürzester
Zeit derm gehab die Experten sind im im
im im regenaustausch wir bekommen alle
Unterlagen zur Verfügung gestellt wir
stellen alle Unterlagen zur Verfügung
alle Sicherheitsabkommen mit den
Niederländern die dazu führen dass wir
sehr eng kooperieren
können muss ich g anschließen warum sind
die Niederlande da so so so amikal uns
gegenüber also unsere Länder s
grundsätlich aber sonst irgendwelche
irgendwelche Vorteile aus diesem aus
dieser gemeinsamen Beschaffung also der
der gemeinsame Vorteil von Beschaffungen
ist manigfach die Frau Bundesministerin
hat schon ausgeführt und ich habe es in
meinen Ausführungen auch erwähnt wenn
man gemeinsam Gerät betreibt ist es
günstiger zu betreiben wenn man
gemeinsam Gerät kauft also es ist
günstiger statt 5ünf eine höhere Anzahl
zu kaufen die Niederländer wollen fünf
kaufen wir so wie die verau
buundesministerin gesagt hat wir erwgen
vier Stück zu kaufen neun äh ist kann
dazu führen dass der Preis günstiger
wird äh das gemeinsame betreiben ich
wder mal so sagen das Ziel von uns allen
ist im Oper für den für Operationen die
die verantwortlichen Politiker anordnen
Gerät zur Verfügung zu stellen und
dieses Gerät gemeinsam betreiben zu
können und zwar ökonomisch effektiv und
effizient betreiben zu können und das
ist der Grund warum nicht nur die
Niederländer sondern auch die Ungarn
auch die Tschechen auch die Portugiesen
daran interessiert sind mit uns
gemeinsam etwas z machen ich glaube dass
wir grundsätzlich in einem positiven
Kontext mit unseren EU Partner naationen
sind und jeder bereit ist mit uns zu
kooperieren so auch die Niederländer
ähm wenn ich es richtig gerechnet habe
reden wir davon 5 600 Millionen Euro
Investitionsvolumen in etwa zusammen
jetzt wissen wir schon dass das
bundesher momentan mehr Geld bekommt äh
und zweifellos auch die Nachbeschaffung
dieser herkol ist grundsätzlich einmal
sinnvoll ist aber wenn man auch weiß wie
hoch beim bundesh im allgemeinen
sozusagen der rückstu an Investitionen
und Neuanschaffungen ist da sozusagen
die Herkules so wichtig dass es nicht
jetzt auch in Hinblick auf den
ukrainekrieg andere Prioritäten gäbe in
der
Verteidigung das ist ein
Transportflugzeug das in erster Linie
für internationale Einsätze gebraucht
wird die möglicherweise gar nicht so
prioritär sind aus unserer Verteidigungs
oder sicherheitsicht seine Frage ist
eine wichtige Frage weil eines ja stimmt
wir haben ja im Zuge des ukrainekrieges
bzw eigentlich schon davor nicht nur das
risikobild adaptiert sondern auch ein
neues streikkräfte Profil entwickelt das
heißt fokussiert zu sein ebenbei auf die
inlandsein Sätze so das Schwergewicht
dorthin auch zu legen wichtig ist dass
wir einen sehr genauen Aufbauplan haben
der sich eben in diese drei Bereiche
teilt der bis zum Jahr 2032 bzw darüber
hinausreicht und der auch seinen
Niederschlag findet im
landesverteidigungs finanzierungsgesetz
und da ist eben auch dieser Betrag und
sie haben jetzt den Betrag
angesprochen der sich rein rechnerisch
ergibt dass der Anzahl der Maschinen
Infrastruktur ist natürlich auch dazu zu
rechnen aber wir dürfen auch nicht
vergessen dass das auch ein Gerät ist
das unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten von
A nach B bringt im Innland im Ausland
erst kürzlich auch die parlamentarische
bundesheerkommission Evakuierungen im
Ausland und wenn man an die jüngste
Vergangenheit auch denkt Transport wenn
sie äh äh nur daran denken was es zu
erledigen gab bei den zahlreichen
Naturkatastrophen wo wir auch helfen
konnten beim Erdbeben auch in der Türkei
das ist eine Notwendigkeit im Bereich
eben der Mobilität die wir zu erledigen
haben und ich glaube es ist wichtig dass
wir diesen Plan eben Schritt für Schritt
abarbeiten sie haben selbstverständlich
recht es ist unglaublicher Rückstand da
umso wichtiger ist es auch dass wir ganz
genau eine Prioritätenliste auch
festgelegt haben was wann erfolgt und
ich glaube das ist wichtig auf der
Zeitschiene auch zu sehen was die
nächsten Schritte im jeweiligen Bereich
auch sind wir beschäftigen uns heute mit
dem Transport Flugzeug sehr viel mit dem
was in der Luft notwendig ist manchmal
geht unter das was auch ganz dringend
notwendig war eben im Bereich der
schützen und der Kampfpanzer da haben
wir ein großes Paket ja letzte Woche
verabschiedet was die die Kampfpanzer
Leopard auch anbelangt das heißt eines
nach dem anderen dieser Versäumnisse der
vergangenen Jahrzehnte auch
aufzuarbeiten das ist unabdingbar
notwendig und wir legen auch
Rechenschaft darüber ab das machen wir
jedes Jahr wir haben einmal den
landesverteidigungsbericht im Parlament
im Ausschuss schon vorgelegt das wird da
in regelmäßigen Abständen eben auch
immer wieder passieren das ist da bei
großen Beschaffungen die wir jetzt zu
tätigen haben auch notwendig dass das
alles auf transparente
Art und Weise auch geschieht und nicht
so wie es in der vergangenhe das eine
oder andere Mal der Fall
war eine Detailfrage die Niederlande
haben ihren typenentscheid ja schon von
einem JR getroffen seitdem wird meines
Wissens noch verhandelt verhandeln die
Niederlande mit der brasilianischen
Regierung sprich auch hier in government
to government Geschäft oder direkt mitm
Hersteller und die eigentliche Frage ist
dieser Vertrag schon abgeschlossen
steigt Österreich bit also in dem Fall
in einem bestehenden Vertrag ein und
übernimmt beispielsweise eine Option
oder ist dieser Vertrag so in
Verhandlung dass man da noch rechtzeitig
einsteigen kann und mitverhandeln kann
wir sind eben und ich glaube das hat
sich aus den Ausführungen von generalmor
wodosek ergeben genau am richtigen
Zeitpunkt auch die Niederlande haben
also der Vertrag ist noch nicht
unterschrieben auch die Niederlande hat
aber die Notwendigkeit eben schnell zu
dieser Nachbeschaffung zu kommen so wie
das für uns auch notwendig ist weil wie
gesagt auch wenn das System der Herkules
bei uns jetzt noch bis 2030 läuft dann
sind zahlreiche Investitionen
erforderlich das ist nicht nur der
jährliche Betriebsaufwand der der der 11
12 Millionen Euro pro Jahr beträgt
sondern eben das was von Jahr zu Jahr
dazu kommt und daher ist auch der
Zeitpunkt jetzt genau genau der Richtige
um eben gemeinsam dann zu einem
günstigeren Preis zu einem Paket auch zu
kommen wo hier so wie wir es ja schon
mit Italien gemacht haben auch bei
unseren Leonardo Hubschraubern alle auch
einen Vorteil haben
davon wenn ich ergänzen darf
Bundesministerin direkte Verhandlung mit
der Firma
Brea also hier wird direkt verhandelt
und wir werden in die Verhandlungen mit
aufgenommen sie haben es der paum
gesprochen von gemeinsam betreiben
kooperieren das klingt ja alles
wunderschön aber was kann man sie dann
konkret drunter vorstellen gibt's dann
irgendwo eine gemeinsam Flieger Werft
oder was heißt es konkret und die zweite
Frage sie haben das jetzt wieder
angesprochen man kann sich Geld sparen
da wollen wir die Rede davon dass
irgendwann in den nächsten Jahren bei
den Hercules eine große Investition
nötig ist kann man sich die dadurch
jetzt schon
ersparen ja das sind ganz wichtige
Fragen also die Fliege Werft
selbstverständlich bitte da keine keine
Sorge
irgendwo da braucht da keine sein weil
die ist in die ist in Linz Hörsching
aber so wie wir das bei der herkul bei
diesem System ja auch hatten das beginnt
eben bei der Ausbildung der Techniker
geht über das was bei den Piloten auch
notwendig ist was man dann eben auch
gemeinsam gemeinsam macht das ist
durchaus durchaus vergleichbar was war
die zweite
Frage der zweite Teil ja die große
Investition ist eben notwendig würde
bedeuten 36,8 Millionen Euro das war die
Schätzung die wir da hatten die da
vorende der technischen des technischen
der Herkules also kurz vor 2030
notwendig wäre und das ist unser Ziel
vom zeitlichen Ablauf wie gesagt 2024
ist das Ziel im ersten Halbjahr den
Vertrag zu unterschreiben und von da an
24 Monate bis 36 Monate das heißt das
Ziel sollte eben sein und das habe ich
von an Beginn an gesagt das Ziel muss
sein dass wir diese teure Investition in
das System der Herkules eben nicht mehr
brauchen das ist wie gesagt das Ziel
wir haben jetzt drei Herkules ist ja die
ganze Zeit die Rede davon jetzt wollen
wir vier EMA kaufen warum vier bzw auch
hat das eine Auswirkung dann auch aufs
Personal haben wir dann ausreichend
Personal um diese vier Maschinen auch zu
betreiben ich habe es vorsichtig
formuliert die Planungen geben gehen
eben in diese in diese Richtung da vi
die Formulierung kann ja dann im Vertrag
auch eine andere sein das darf man ja
nie vergessen wir hatten das ja auch bei
den Hubschraubern wo man im Vertrag dann
eine Optionsmöglichkeit mit dazu
aufnimmt aber dazu sind eben auch die
entsprechenden
die entsprechenden Gespräche mit den
Niederlanden auch noch noch fertig zu
führen ähm was war zweite Frage war off
Personal Personal ja Personal das ist
das ist generell eine Frage ich habe das
eingangs mit angesprochen die wir immer
mitdenken müssen den gesamten Aufbau
Plan anbelangt
müssen wir natürlich auch sehen
dass wir dass wir die entsprechend gut
ausgebildeten das gut ausgebildete
Personal auch bekommen und das ist
parallel das muss parallel passieren wir
haben aber durchaus in Hörsching ganz
gute Möglichkeiten das ist ja das ist ja
bekannt und an dem ist jetzt ganz
intensiv ganz intensiv zu arbeiten jede
dieser Beschaffungen hat auch immer mit
zu ber berücksichtigen dass wir das
entsprechende Personal auch brauchen
dazu heißt ja nicht nur die Pilotinnen
Piloten sondern eben auch die
entsprechenden
Techniker der letzte große baustin jetzt
noch hoffen bei den luftkäften sind die
Advan chrainer gibt's gibt's einen einen
aktuellen Stand oder einen Zeitplan oder
einen
Fahrplan der Fahrplan so wie auch immer
gesagt
2024 werden wir uns dann Wiedersehen die
Arbeiten laufen sehr
intensiv in welche Richtung es gehen
wird und ob es ausschließlich ein
chatrainer sein wird oder eine
Kombination sein wird von drohen das ist
es was jetzt ganz intensiv auch
bearbeitet wird und vom Zeitplan wie
gesagt ich neige dazu mich an das zu
halten was ich gesagt habe also 2024
werden wir die nächsten Schritte dann
verkünden bitteü
kann4 20 war wenn Sie genau nachlesen
wann sie wenn sie genau nachlesen aber
wie gesagt da ist auch alles äh besser
was schneller geht
ähm meine Vorgänger haben sich damals
nicht darum gekümmert die SA 105
auszuscheiden die tatsächlich eine
Gefahr dann auch schon war für
diejenigen die in dem Fluggerät da
drinnen sitzen ähm ich habe diese
Entscheidung aus Verantwortung getroffen
wir haben jetzt mit dem entsprechenden
Budget und mit dem
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
die Möglichkeit entsprechende nachbes
Beschaffungen auch zu tätigen und wie
auch von ihnen schon angesprochen es hat
natürlich der Ukraine Krieg sehr vieles
verändert und damit auch die Frage der
Entscheidung
auch in den drohenbereich noch stärker
Fähigkeiten eben auch zu erwerben und
sobald wir da fertig sind sie können
sicher sein dass im rüstungsdirekt und
seine Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern mit Sicherheit nicht Fahrt
wird und die das sehr sehr schnell auch
erarbeiten werden
eine Nachfrage noch dazu 2024 haben alle
verstanden aber ich glaube die drei die
gefragt wurden für den chiner müssen
jetzt glaube ich Ende des Monats im
Oktober irgendwann ihre Antworten
abgeben nur dieche
2024 typenentscheidung oder Vertrag
Stellung ist dann wieder ein Jahr
vielleicht noch dazwischen die
typenentscheidung auch erst 2024
das danke bitte sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
das Fighter aircraft mit der Möglichkeit
auch auszubilden also zu trainieren ist
derzeit im Prinzip in einer Phase wo ich
rfis an die jeweiligen Hersteller
gestellt habe Ende September werde ich
die Rückantworten bekommen und nachdem
die Rückantworten bei uns eingetroffen
sind werden wir prüfen
wie die Hersteller in der Lage sind
unseren Forderungen zu entsprechen und
nachdem die Arbeit bei uns relativ zügig
abläuft würde ich mal sagen auch im
Hinblick auf die Frage wie wir den den
Aufbauplan abarbeiten wird die
verbundesminister von uns jedenfalls in
diesem Jahr die entsprechenden
Unterlagen erhalten und die Frage wann
die verbundesministerin die
typenentscheidung trifft ist dann in
ihrer Entscheidung aber wir arbeiten
daran dass wir ein Fighter aircraft mit
der Möglichkeit Piloten zu trainieren
beschaffen
werden nachdem es keine weiteren Fragen
zur aktuellen Thematik zur c390 gibt
eine abschließende Frage die uns online
erreicht hat kann sich Österreich
vertraglich absichern sollte es zu
technischen Kinderkrankheiten kommen
selbstverständlich so wie wir dieses
Jahr bei jedem Rüstungsgeschäft
tun danke sehr damit erkläre ich die
Pressekonferenz für beendet danke
vielmals